new in theaters this weekend scary
stories to tell in the dark Dora and the
lost city of gold and the art of racing
in the rain well you see this is your
weekend ticket based on the book series
of short stories that screw me up in the
head as a child scary stories to tell
him that dark follows for teens to
decide to explore an old abandoned house
when they find a book of scary stories
sera bellows his book when the stories
write themselves and it all comes alive
what I said upon reading them they
realize that not only are their names in
the stories but that those stories are
now coming gruesomely to life as the
film is produced by Guillermo del Toro
there's no shortage of creatively
grotesque creatures a keen eye will also
notice the familiar story names in the
book as well as the haunting images
yikes my dude this movies for you if
you're looking for some scary stuff this
summer do you love the books and you
want to relive them in live-action or
you're too young to have read them but
now it's your turn to get screwed up in
the head did you watch Dora the Explorer
growing up great cuz Dora and the lost
city of gold comes out this weekend in a
sort of fast board from the animated
children's show Dora is now a teen and
is leaving her jungle adventures to head
off to public school there she has a
tricky time adapting just be cool door
okay what is this where did you transfer
from the jungle it isn't long before
trouble finds her and she's forced to
set off on an adventure with her friends
to find her parents and maybe even the
City of Lost gold everyone from the
cartoon appears to be here
Swiper Diego her backpack and even boots
who's voiced by Danny Trejo which yeah
sure why not
this movie is for you if you grew up on
the cartoon door of the Explorer a fun
comedy adventure for the whole family
sounds like a good time and lastly the
art of racing in the rain comes out this
weekend based on the novel of the same
name the movie tells the story of the
life and times of racecar driver Danny
Swift played by Milo Ventimiglia and
just as importantly his dog Enzo in this
story Enzo has just as much character as
Denny and has even narrated by Kevin
Costner no one knows what curves life
with
but if a driver has the courage to
create his own conditions the trailer
doesn't fully give up where the novel
eventually goes and where the movie may
go and I won't either you'll just have
to go check it out for yourself this one
is for you if you love the novel and
want to see it come to life you'll love
a buddy dog story with some heart or if
you didn't realize that race car spelled
backwards is race car that is your
weekend ticket well you see and check
back next week to see your favorite
Morgan Freeman presidential Morgan
Freeman
[Music]